[Music]
friday edition of pft ot some of the
things we weren't able to get to during
pft live big cat and i talked a lot
about the thursday night game and some
other topics in the nfl i want to go
back to the thursday night game we
ranted in two different segments about
the past interference replay review
procedures the failure to drop a flag
not once but twice in the second half
when it appeared clear obvious and
egregious that pass interference had
indeed happened the worst one that i've
seen all year
was the avante maddox
hand to the chin
of marquez valdez scantling of the
packers as the ball was coming in and
before the ball came in that's the kind
of thing that has to be overturned via
replay review and called defensive pass
interference that is rams saints light
it's not quite as egregious as what we
saw in the nfc championship game but
it's in that same vein and it's exactly
the kind of thing that i have said this
standard needs to address it's the what
the hell question when you're saying
after you see the play what the hell why
isn't there a flag that's when there
needs to be a flag but earlier in the
game
there was an offensive pass interference
call that rarely gets made but now that
al riveron has been dropping the flag
for offensive pass interference after
the fact the blocking more than one yard
downfield last year i don't think it
gets called it happened last night on a
touchdown by the philadelphia eagles and
there was a call on the field of
offensive pass interference for zach
ertz blocking downfield he engaged the
player less than a yard from the line of
scrimmage he continued to push beyond
that the flag was thrown
after further review the flag was picked
up no offensive pass interference the
touchdown stands and that was surprising
to me because if we're going to truly
respect clear and obvious
significant hindrance blocking down
field whatever the standard is and again
with offensive passenger visible for the
throw it's about blocking an opponent
more than a yard downfield it was
clearly there i don't know why they
picked it up unless they've just decided
we're no longer calling this anymore
unless unless it's clearly more than a
yard downfield unless it's three or four
or five yards down here but we're not
going to call it if the block gets
started within a yard i don't know but
my point is this if the standard is
clear and obvious to overturn
it wasn't clear and obvious that there
was no offensive pass interference there
so another reason why the nfl needs to
reconsider number one having replay
review for past interference calls and
non-calls and i think they won't use it
next year but number two for replay
review generally because it's not an
easy thing to do it sounds easy it's not
easy especially when you know the eyes
of the football world are upon you and
your boss may be hovering over your
shoulder while you're trying to properly
apply the standard they need to bring
back dean blandino whatever it takes 2
million 3 million 5 million 10 million
whatever it takes they've got the money
it's the most important job in the nfl
during football season it's the most
powerful position i know how riverron
would disagree with that but who has
more power right now over the game than
the person who can decide touchdowns no
touchdowns 50 yards of field position no
50 yards of field position
right big play wiped out big play stands
it's one person who has that power over
every
single
game
dean blandino told me a year or two ago
the nfl didn't properly value that
position that's why he left for fox the
nfl needs to value that position the nfl
needs to bring back dean blandino or get
rid of that position and go back to
letting the referees in the stadium make
the decisions on replay review
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports